[Music]
i find myself following the advice that
it is better to ask for forgiveness
than ask for permission
the end result i'm often apologizing
today
we will explore apologies forgiveness
and happiness i'm matt abrahams and i
teach strategic communication at
stanford graduate school of business
welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
i am excited and really interested to
speak with dr fred luskin who is the
director of the stanford forgiveness
project and the author of two books
forgive for good a proven prescription
for health and happiness and stress-free
for good 10 proven life skills for
health and happiness
welcome to the podcast fred thanks for
joining me thanks for having me on let's
get started
from your perspective why is forgiving
important and can you share your view on
the forgiving process and the steps
involved
well desmond tutu says without
forgiveness there is no future
so implying that if you don't let go of
the past release your bitterness you're
living in the past
that is really dangerous for
relationships and
in terms of i know what you teach is
communication
you don't want to be just negotiating
and relitigating the past you want to
have
communication now about what's going on
now
we through the forgiveness project have
developed a nine step process to
forgiveness and that's the essence of
our work
it goes from awarenesses of what
forgiveness is and isn't to some
practices the end result being you end
up with an entirely different story that
you tell yourself about what happened
fascinating
how does apologizing fit into this
forgiving process and what are the steps
that are involved in apologizing i find
myself doing it quite often
well in particular if you don't want to
ask for permission you're going to have
a good number of apologies
apology is one of the few things that
research shows actually facilitates
forgiveness and there's not that many a
sincere apology is a facilitator
a sincere apology is what's important
and from what i understand most
apologies are not that useful because
they end up saying
i'm sorry that you feel bad
or i'm sorry that you're upset
a sincere apology says i did wrong
my wrong
led to your upset i own both my own
behavior and your response
i'm sorry about that and if i can i will
make amends
so that's the fullness of apology we add
to that in terms of the forgiveness
piece
is not only would it be nice to make
amends but it would be good if i can
undergo whatever processes are needed so
i'm less likely to do it again
so if i do something because i have a
bad habit do something to work on that
habit if i'm a drunk stop drinking
if i have a bad temper acknowledge and
get some help
but the apology is that
i see your heart i own
my own behavior that caused that i'm
sorry and is there anything to do to
make it better
so it starts with taking responsibility
and includes empathy and that's what's
so hard that many many people struggle
to admit their flaws
and own the fact that behavior of theirs
caused other people's suffering or their
own suffering such as you know i did
something really stupid and blew off the
test or something yes
interesting so those people who listen
into the podcast know i'm a huge fan of
structure and how you can structure your
communication and it sounds like
a recommendation you have as you start
by acknowledging your responsibility and
what you did
and then move to talk about how what you
did impacted
the other or others and from there can
talk about how you can go about making
amends
that would be a good thing i'm going to
say even more deeply though
i would advocate for the value of
mindfulness or even a buddhist-based
awareness practice that
it's really good to pay attention to
both our behavior our thoughts and how
they influence other people you don't
want it to be limited just to when you
cause harm
because in a deeper way the more
important communication
or the positive or facilitative
communication so
to say to somebody i noticed what you
did that was good or i noticed that i
was feeling love towards you
those are
mindfulness-based communications that
are really helpful for the relationship
the apology and the forgiveness are
repair parts there are also facilitator
parts wow i almost think of the yin yang
where you need to both together to have
the whole relationship with the person
and the research on relationship success
they used to think that it was mostly
that people could
fight in a certain way but now they're
finding that a large part of
relationship success is does your
partner or your friend acknowledge your
successes
and the more you feel like you can share
your positive world with somebody the
better the relationship feels
i had read that and you just reminded me
of that that it's the celebrating of the
successes big and little that is also
critically important critically
important
wonderful thank you for that
you know on this podcast fred we have
often talked about how our mindset and
approach affects our communication but
we've not explored our internal
self-talk something you've thought a lot
about and i'm wondering can you help us
understand the importance of self-talk
and how it affects how we interact with
others
i mean we're always evaluating
experiences so
i mean i might you know a good question
to you good answer to me
not good question from you not good
question you know answer from me
we have a
almost relentless inner dialogue that
evaluates things
if we just allow that critic praiser to
go we're pulled all over the place so
you know good question all right i feel
better bad question i feel worse good
answer i feel good bad question i feel
bad it's an emotional rollercoaster
so when people have meta strategies
above that that can modulate the
self-talk they usually have more control
over it and their emotions so a mindset
is a word for that so i have a growth
mindset so i want to learn how to have
more constructive self-talk
the fixed mindset that's just who i am
right i teach like happiness mindset
so what kind of self-talk will make me
happier
but if you have the happiness mindset
then you look at your self-talk from
that perspective is it working towards
my deeper goal
so you can actually do work on your
mindset which then
influences and affects how you approach
your communication and the different
ways in which you interact with other
people i think it's a bi-directional
communication that when you wake up in
the morning we have a handful of very
basic inner premises
and that reflects in that self-talk and
how we use the self-talk but we can also
look at the self-talk and pull back and
recognize what our basic
deepest goals and values are so it's
a bi-directional communication i've
explored this a little bit when i
help people manage anxiety they have
around communication and we have lots of
negative self-talk that we say to
ourselves i'm gonna mess up i can't
believe i'm in the situation i'm a
failure right and if you start
understanding what you're saying to
yourself you can then begin to change
that self-talk and in your words that
mindset that can help you feel better
and more confident so i see a lot of
synergy between what you're saying and
some of the work i do
i want to tap into this notion of
happiness because your focus on
forgiveness really is part of your
larger work on happiness can you help us
connect the dots between forgiveness
apology mindset and happiness how do
those all connect together and are there
are there a couple things we could do to
be more happy
there was a book maybe 15 20 years ago
that the dalai lama wrote called the art
of happiness
and in that book the thing he talked
about that was most influential to me
was if you want to be happy practice the
conditions that lead to happiness
if you want to be unhappy practice the
conditions that lead to unhappiness so
within that framework of strategies that
are more likely to produce happiness and
those more likely to produce unhappiness
one of the strongest that produces
unhappiness is grievance
is walking around with an unresolved
grudge against something
another one that leads to unhappiness is
bitterness that people feel life hasn't
been fair to them and a third that we
see all the time is just self-pity like
poor me it didn't work out the way i
hope those are practices that the dalai
lama says lead to unhappiness
practices that we teach that lead more
to happiness forgiveness is resolving
those grudges
gratitude is the opposite of bitterness
and a certain self-affirmation
would be a contrary practice that would
lead to more happiness
the key definer of that is again
what we practice influences how happy we
are it's not based primarily in external
experiences it's an inner way of holding
those experiences
the cataloging of the things we do to
make ourselves unhappy and make happy is
actually very propound i find myself
really reflecting
i find that one of the things that makes
me unhappy is i am over scheduled and
i'm busy rushing around of course and so
giving ourselves time and space and
prior to us starting the recording you
shared that meditation is something you
do it's something i do and it strikes me
that just taking time to reflect to give
yourself that space in your schedule and
maybe even to meditate are ways to help
allow us to explore these ideas but also
to make ourselves happier
i mean meditation is
a profound
tool
that some people think is
another necessary type of consciousness
that we minimize so we have waking
sleeping dreaming
there are people who postulate that
meditation and is in and of itself a
brain patterning that is required for
our highest functioning
fred you've been teaching these skills
for a long time and i'm curious if you
have any best practices you rely on to
help people learn
these types of tools so when you teach
these tools what are things you have
found help you
to educate people about these
i'm going to say the two that would be
most essential for my simple
practices are abdominal breathing
where you really focus on your core like
somewhere in the the center like the
martial arts put it like a inch below
your navel right but inhaling and
exhaling from that point and making sure
the exhalation is deep so the next
inhalation fills
that's essential and the other essential
practice is simply thank you
so i'm going to say the other practice
is to train your mind so that you find
all the ways that people are kind and
good to you and all the ways that you're
supported in the world
and that results in a heck of a lot more
thank yous than most people end up
having but just noticing like oh there's
a water fountain wow that's good i don't
have to go dig up water
and if you create a small attitude of
thank you from that that in and of
itself lowers stress but again it opens
the perception that the world is a safe
place
and that probably is the most important
thing that we can create for ourselves
an attitude of gratitude is a great that
is a great way and and we've definitely
talked about the importance of breath
and communication and relaxation of
course and it's great to hear it echoed
in your ideas
before we end i'd like to ask you the
same three questions i ask everybody who
joins me you up for that
sure all right
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title
what would that be
try as best you can for kind speech
try as best you can for kind speech i
like that it's not directive it's
inviting and it's also realistic yeah
yeah don't set expectations that are
unachievable very good a lot of us set
expectations for ourselves that invite
stress
absolutely i like that it's in some ways
it's forgiving yourself
before you even start i like to have to
yeah
let me ask you question number two who
is a communicator that you admire and
why
i had a teacher
who
when i was getting my first graduate
degree at san jose state
i watched him do therapy
and his listening was so profound
his attention was so focused on someone
else
that struck me as how deeply valuable
that was for any kind of communication
practice
because he was all there in his
listening
and that observing behavior taught me
something that was
really profoundly helpful in my career
i love that i asked you a question about
a communicator and you immediately
defaulted to a listener and i think that
is so important in our communication to
remember that listening is as important
if not more important when we're
communicating
question number three
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe
that you're communicating when somebody
who is
similar to you in
deep values and aspirations
that it's your responsibility to be
clear and understandable
and
you have opportunities if you don't do
it right the first time
if you're humble to get more attempts at
it
so i like that you're seeking similarity
in terms of attitudes beliefs and values
yeah and i love that last part about
be humble and try it again one of the
practices that we do teaching
forgiveness is some aspect of buddhist
loving kindness practice
so one of those practices is basically
just like me
they want to be happy
just like me they want to be at peace
just like me whatever and i think if the
communication matters you'd want to have
that somewhere in your consciousness
that just like me
they want similar things
so seeking commonality and similarity is
a way to kind of that would be my if i
had to choose one yeah i like that i
like that well fred i certainly have to
end this by saying thank you you've
taught me a lot about gratitude of
forgiveness and apology
i find your work fascinating and so
needed in our world today thank you for
taking the time and helping us improve
not just our communication but perhaps
our happiness
thank you
you've been listening to think fast talk
smart the podcast a production of
stanford graduate school of business
this episode was produced by andrew
steltzer jenny luna and me matt abrahams
find more resources and connect with us
online by searching for think fast talk
smart on linkedin we'd love to connect
with you
please download more episodes of our
show wherever you get your podcasts